how to get rich with crypto part 1 we're
gonna take some notes here turn to a new
page here I'm gonna study up with our
guy bitcoin fund manager let's figure
out how to get rich with crypto together
he's gonna he's gonna break it down with
us okay we give you signals that make
you two hundred three hundred percent
per trade if you're using 30 40 50 80 X
leverage okay step one make two hundred
and three hundred percent with 80 X
leverage now lesser people would call it
risky and a way to blow up your account
and potentially go into debt but that's
because those do people don't understand
leverage now there's always a risk to
trading with leverage there's always a
risk to breathing
that's exactly right guys you need to
realize that trading with high amounts
of leverage
it's risky sure but so is breathing
breathing hey you take the risk of
breathing why not take the risk of an a
hundred x leverage account obviously
there's no guarantee in life there's no
guarantee that you'll be any of us will
be awake or a live breathing tomorrow
but having said that
and you can sit there day trading all
day long you can just quit your job to
just day trade right with us do trading
24 hours a day and make tons of money
but oh we got a lot there we got a lot
there day trade full-time oh this is
good stuff this really good stuff you
can just quit your job fire your boss
and just just let your job quit your job
quit going to school quick o-5 don't
want to miss that quit going to school
okay okay quit everything oh okay great
six quit everything alright alright
thank you wow these are some high level
tips for us you know newbie gamblers we
don't know how to make as much money so
how to be rich let's put that down okay
taking notes the smart thing to do is
invest in yourself the smart thing to do
is just grow your cash and the easiest
way to do it is to join Bitcoin - signal
stutter but o7 invest in myself in best
in myself
yeah invest in myself but quit school
right cuz I need to quit school I I need
to invest myself but I also need to quit
my job but I'm gonna join this guy's day
trading group okay okay I got it now of
course at this point we probably need to
learn how to 80 X 50 X 100 X leverage
trade so how do we do that
[Music]
alright guys you see that we're doing 80
X 90 X hundred X hundred 25 X long
detours
you can do that too to do that you gotta
be really faster you gonna want a super
fast internet connection you're gonna
want to at least two different Springs
one for our telegram room one for the
Bitcoin chart and one just to have your
trading interface open so that you can
go 400 X BAM dandy it's gone that's how
fast you have to do that's why you need
you're gonna need two to three
cellphones or two cell phones
Wow okay so what's next
some of you will become very rich when
you do it will become obvious to those
around you how hard you worked and help
brilliant you are
and then it'll become clear that they're
not as brilliant as you are and they
cannot work as hard as you did then this
feels bad
it feels so bad they have to start
making up lies about you and say you
cheated you were somehow unethical oh
boy here we go this is what the haters
always say you know whenever you start a
signal group where you tell me with a
hundred x leverage they tell you you're
unethical which just really pisses all
of us rich people off and they grow old
[Music]
with a simple comfort that at least they
lived in honest virtuous life whereas
the reality is don't forget to smash
like and subscribe thank you they died
poor failed liars
[Music]